this baby is 35 days old when Monday's
catastrophic earthquake hit turkey's
Eastern province of karaman Maharaj she
was already in intensive care
and this one as well
his heartbeat slowed down when he's
asleep
16 infants were transferred from the
epicenter in karaman maharash to the
capital Ankara two days ago
they were all intensive care but their
hospitals were evacuated either for
safety reasons or to treat survivors
all of them have IDs but the authorities
haven't been able to reach their
families
babies are in good shape we do
ultrasounds for checkup purposes one of
our babies was born at 28 weeks and the
other at 33 following the completion of
their eye examinations we will plan
their discharge
and this tiny Survivor was rescued from
the runes the woman who discovered her
scribbled baby of the rubble on her
forehead and left a note on her chest
telling where she was found
16 babies separated from their families
were evacuated from their Hometown which
now resembles a war-torn city
after being rescued from the rubles some
babies were able to receive medical
treatment premature babies on the other
hand will have to remain in intensive
care
they are being attended by Foster
mothers appointed by the ministry of
family and Social Services
we will definitely keep a close eye on
our babies these patients growth and
development should be monitored at
regular intervals in our Outpatient
Clinic
as these innocent babies fight for their
lives in the ICU authorities continue to
search for their missing families